[Music]
listen this is big news last time I got
to see you was interviewed about Dancing
with the Stars here you are back in
reality TV this time Celebrity Big
Brother man you are you a fan of the
show I have never seen the show he never
saw okay I have I have now yeah once I
signed up I went and watched binge
watched a little bit but you know I
didn't realize there's like 40 with 41
episodes a season or something like that
a season but you know yeah but those
seasons were were long but I put they
were good I mean I actually got into it
actually got a cut myself off oh my god
I'm gonna go check out that season I
want to get a few different people so
yeah it's not around
Ward you pick up for Washington DC like
the other strategies there's alliances I
you know that it was a thing I had to
when I first was asked to do the game
it's really tough for me because I'm a
very straightforward person a very
honest person yeah very loyal I mean if
you ask anybody knows me one of the
first things come back my buddy how you
describe Chuck he's loyal yeah so I had
to kind of figure out you know but this
is a game it's like a fight yeah we
accept certain rules like if you and I
fight we're gonna go out there I'm gonna
try to hurt you I know will you be my
best friend but I'm gonna still try
knock your head off for a fight it's
gonna be a bad night for me after it so
after it's over I'll be fine fine I'm
gonna be Stoll gonna be in trouble
but yeah I get I didn't want to
interrupt your train of thought I get
what you're going yeah but but you know
the game but there's a game so that's
part of the game yeah I'm gonna play the
game to the best of my ability okay let
me ask you this there's sometimes
sometimes the big the strong guys you
know the athletes sometimes they get a
target put on their back kind of early
in the game of how you you know like if
that happens how are you gonna there's
water strategy to try to avoid that why
it's the one thing I have going for me
with avoiding being a big target isn't
everybody expects me to be a jerk like a
cocky jerk usually oh yeah they've never
met me
come in and if I come in a half way nice
if I'm just a normal person they think
I'm the nicest guy in the world
monster yeah so so I think I will use
that to my advantage of people being be
nice I mean as far as challenges go I
can't no I can't throw which at people
then but win the first one I'm like I
can't throw a challenge it's not in me
yeah I don't like to lose it anything
yeah that's part of this game like like
you'll see me act mad I'm actually I'm
hoping someone's gonna worry about me
being mad after the game now I know it's
a game I know it's a game and it's not
so after it's over I'm not mad at anyone
for playing the game they want to play
it but I'm hoping some guys will worry
about it well I don't want because I'm
off after the game right exactly mad at
me when we leave here I use out a little
bit so that's right that's right like
exactly if I bump into you in a dark
alley after the show raps like lookout
for me kind of feel right cuz I was
gonna someone it was someone you know so
some of us that stab me in the back on
the show I finally let them off for the
past like it's nothing you can't do that
I think that I'm not expected I don't
you say like what would be the
intimidating thing like let's say on the
show you know you you're put because
this is good because I don't think I've
ever seen this kind of strategy in a
sense you're sort of saying like if you
wronged me here when this raps like
without bad feel is that the idea that's
the idea but it's got to be very subtle
oh yeah yeah
okay I can't I don't want to say it
outright yeah but I wanted to have that
feel so it's it's a little it's gonna be
real soft I think oh it's gotta be soft
but but it's easy again people with the
misconception of how I am I tell you a
secret just by looking at you it's
intended just by just by looking at you
I wouldn't want to like piss you off on
the show you know I mean right and I'm
gonna use that to my advantage if you
really get to know me you know me better
than that I'm not that I'm not that guy
but I keep that persona up a little bit
during the show cuz I don't want anyone
at least these are of your honor I want
anyone coming after me okay that's good
strategy I like that
I like that so Dancing with the Stars we
talked about the fact that you were on
that show do you think this is going to
be easier or harder what do you you know
as far as difficult or drama difficult
and drama I think this will be this
would be this will be more involved as
far as the strategy and thinking and I
think I'm going to stay on my feet is
good it's it's it's tough you got to
stay on their feet 24/7 here especially
with all the curve balls they throw it
see this isn't that's the hardest thing
for me I'm a strategist I like to make
sure you know I like to plan my things
out five moves ahead
but these change things up so you never
know what's gonna happen so your
strategies got to be able to be able to
move it's gotta evolve
gonna be able to evolve your strategy
fast okay what about is there anything I
mean you don't seem like the kind of guy
that's Ephrata very much but are you
nervous we most nervous about going into
this competition I'm most nervous about
the curveballs I mean I don't want I
don't want I mean I think one of the one
of the seasons I saw the guy he would
have had Paula Cody would have Paul out
and see the 19 or dad pull out second
episode was gone but he had had an a
minute where we got to be protected and
I mean I think he waited near he was
still in the show it see episode 21 for
sure yeah I mean he's still going so
it's it's a you know those curveballs
you get everything planned everything is
ready to go and right last second oh no
you're gonna take your competitiveness
from being an athlete and is that kind
of like Drive you to try and win this I
I don't know I I can't not win I need I
need to win I it's one of those things I
I will I'll do anything within the rules
to win so expect me to do some crazy
stuff because I there's a lot of things
allowing these rules yeah yeah that's
right - what you're not allowed to do
actually I expected - I mean honestly
you gotta expect people to stab people
the backhand and make alliances and make
another lance and move on it's got a
play guys against each other what if
somebody wants to you to teach them how
to fight would you like kind of throw it
out a little bit well yeah we're gonna
have a lot of free time on there I
wouldn't mind showing some guys some
stuff and you know I'm sure if I'm
showing them some moves they'd they do
owe me something a little bit all right
we'll help during the show yeah that's
right show up some self-defense moves
and then they may have your back when
it's needed what celebrities would you
like to see on there if you had your
pick I don't know the pick you don't
know you know I get one you know you get
Jared Allen he retires a good friend of
mine
oh my god my friends I get good good
either yeah get on there I'm good
you people know me to be right now one
of my got some solar friends that know
me for my to know me outside the outside
the game any celebrity names come to
mind that you really would hope that's
not on the show you know that I I don't
have anybody I just like that much then
I wouldn't care if they're on the show I
think anybody I like weird people and
different people I'm hoping some there's
some great characters on the shows where
he'll I'm seeing the ring and it forgive
me for not knowing your your status your
arrogance get married okay so show
manses are out the winner was your was
your wife worried about you taking on
taking this up no my wife's excited
about me taking [ __ ] and she said don't
worry you're free to do whatever you
need to to win the game wait does that
mean she's giving you a Hall Pass
hi dad I've ever heard
all right a Hall Pass suppose it you
know within reason I like it so I'm
gonna ask you one more time sir answer
this already but I've been asking again
why are you gonna win Celebrity Big
Brother I'm gonna win because people
don't expect me to play the way I'll
play I play within the rules I'm known
as a in-1 know guys have more
I'm honest I'm straightforward but
that's not the rules of this game that's
not the rules of engagement I'm playing
I'm gonna play by the rules of
engagement
you